und in bamberg cloud ein abiturient
prüfungsaufgaben daraufhin müssen dann
bayernweit die klausuren ausgetauscht
werden und mehr details zu diesem
unglaublichen backhand jörg völkerling
wie war es überhaupt möglich dass ein
abiturient an die prüfungsaufgaben
gekommen ist ja der verdächtige heißt
johannes t ist 18 jahre alt hat es in
diesem sommer am kaiser heinrich
gymnasium in bamberg selbst sein abitur
gemacht ich stehe hier etwas oberhalb
wir sehen auf die stadt bamberg und dort
mitten im grünen umgeben von hohen
hacken wird seit mehr fast 500 jahren
oberfrankens elite ausgebildet an diesem
kaiser heinrich gymnasium hat der erste
bayerische ministerpräsident sein abi
gemacht der bundesjustizminister thomas
dehler und die bestseller autorin tanja
kinkel
doch was dann in der nacht vom 5 16 auf
den siebzehnten mal geschah das hat es
hier noch nie gegeben unbekannte
unbekannte zunächst unbekannte brachen
also in das schulsekretariat ein und
öffneten den tresor in dem unter anderem
die aufgaben für die deutsch abi klausur
gelagert waren
es entstand ein sachschaden von 500 euro
was aber viel gravierender war für ganz
bayern mussten daraufhin die deutsch abi
klausuren ausgetauscht werden kurz vor
bevor sie geschrieben werden sollten und
das auch noch in diesem ganzen corona
stresszeiten und es wurde es ging man
ging zunächst davon aus dass es ein
besonders schwerer einbruch sozusagen
vorliegt aber es gab keine
tatverdächtigen es gab einen kreis von
technik schülern technikaffinen schülern
die dann sozusagen einen tag bevor diese
prüfung geschrieben wurde besuch von der
kripo bekommen haben hausdurchsuchungen
ihrer handys ihrer festplatten wurden
beschlagnahmt
nur weil sie in der technik gruppe waren
und weil man wohl für diesen einbruch
technisches verständnis auch das stellte
sich heraus dass diese vier vollkommen
unbescholten waren und letztlich ganz zu
unrecht da aus ihrer abi vorbereitung
herausgerissen wurden